Today, hatred mail does make a triumphant
return to the show. If you don't remember
what hatriot mail is, here's a reminder.
We are getting to the orange juice of this
investigation. So God bless the United States.
America. Teary eyed man written by patriots
who, hey, David Pakman because of America
and because freedom.
Yeah. So hatriot male is when a professional
voiceover artist does interpretive readings
of the hate mail that I get. Here is one from
someone who simultaneously seems just obsessed
with me, but also seems to very much dislike
me.
Who is David Pakman? Is he married? And Flotard
below me is correct. Women pick their man.
I mean, she should have married you a loser
YouTube commentator. She seems like she has
an okay life. First world problems are Pacman.
You are a loser. Sign up to become unhinged.
Loon with Pacman. Report the news of Trump's
victories. I'm not a fan of David Cook called
Bagman, surprisingly, or maybe not.
I mean, maybe this is actually a common psychological
phenomena. It's really common that some of
the people who seem to despise me the most
because of my political views and the program
I host also seem obsessed with the minutia
of everything I'm doing, everything I'm saying,
my life and whatever else. It's actually not
altogether uncommon among hatriot. And maybe
that's surprising. Maybe it's not. I don't
know. But remember that you can fight hatriot
TISM in your communities by using the coupon
code Hatriot 40. Any membership at Join Patman
dot com can be instantly discounted by 40
percent with the coupon code hatriot 40. The
hatriot. Hate it when that coupon code is
used and it's spelled hkt r i o t for zero.